[Music]
the adult human brain average with 3/4
water
composed of a few thousand known
chemical compounds designed into a dozen
billion nerve cells the brain burns
oxygen and glucose at rates 10 times the
average of other tissues at rest day and
night night and day for a lifetime
the human brain site of trillions of
electrical events and tiny Jets of
chemicals that signal messages between
nerve cells the control center of the
body the storehouse of memories the seat
of consciousness awesome and function
yet after three centuries of
increasingly intensive study still
largely unknown at the University of
California San Diego two new techniques
for exploring brains have been developed
the first is cine morphology by means of
cine morphology thousands of sections of
a brain are photographed and displayed
in smooth succession
structures appear and succeed one
another as if in continuous flow
blood vessels can be injected to trace
the details of the vascular plan cine
morphology on frozen brains permits
staining that will distinguish white and
gray matter to achieve these unique
records a fixed brain is first embedded
in plastic
then the plastic block is placed on a
giant microtome by means of elaborate
mechanical and electronic controls this
permit is programmed to cut away a very
thin section of the brain as little as
25 microns
following the each cut the brain is
automatically moved in front of a motion
picture camera the cut surface of the
brain is illuminated and the camera
photographs the new surface that has
been exposed by the removal of the thin
sliced by the microtome a typical cine
morphology film for an entire brain
depicts more than 10,000 surfaces each
anatomical part is photographed in its
natural position in its exact relations
with all other parts the resulting
motion picture films can be studied
framed by a frame or viewed in smooth
succession forwards or backwards at
faster slow-motion speeds since 1967
some 60 cine morphology films have been
created at the University of California
San Diego
this cine morphology film shows a brain
that has been sliced in the horizontal
plane some 7000 individual surfaces
appear from crown to spinal cord without
staining the cerebral cortex appears
cream-colored and the white matter looks
slightly pinkish
The Scindia microtome is now cutting
through the corpus callosum a dense
bundle of fibres which bridges between
the two cerebral hemispheres on each
side appear the two lateral ventricles
the basal ganglia which contribute to
posture and locomotion now emerge then
the thalamus surrounding the third
ventricle
the hypothalamus separates from the
brainstem the brainstem contains a
narrow ventricular aqueduct which
interconnects
the third and fourth ventricles the
cerebellum reveals its beautiful
fan-like structures the cortex of the
cerebellum shows hundreds of repeated
identical folia which seemed to succeed
one another in cine morphology like the
opening of petals in an awakening flower
the cerebellum can be seen to rise out
of the brainstem on three stout
pedunculated son each side the brainstem
contains connections between the
forebrain
cerebellum and spinal cord it also
embodies the sights and origins and
relays for the cranial nerves now the
same images can be reversed in order to
view the brain from spinal cord to crown
the film is now seen at twice the
previous viewing speed
[Music]
[Music]
Cine morphology has revealed that every
brain is found to be unique just as our
faces are
in this brain the ventricle opens up
before the corpus callosum appears
[Music]
in this particular brain the thalamus is
comparatively squared off and not so
smoothly rounded as in most other brains
the form of the cortex the shape of each
individual nucleus the configuration of
each functional system all are each
recognizably somewhat different in one
brain from any other a second technique
for studying the brain also developed at
the University of California San Diego
converts cine morphology films to
computer graphic display individual
frames of cine morphology films are
projected onto large sheets of paper and
any desired structures of the human
brain are then carefully traced
[Music]
these tracings are of course unique to
the individual brain
[Music]
each of these tracings is placed on a
special easel
[Music]
when an electronic pin touches any point
on the tracing the exact location of
this point
is transferred to the memory of a
computer the locations of many thousands
of points from each tracing provides a
replica of that tracing in the computer
[Music]
point by point tracing by tracing the
information committed by camera to cine
morphology is preserved in the computer
[Music]
the computer a wonderful assistant of
the human brain and be programmed to
call up and display the pinpoints of
neuroanatomy so laborious ly traced
either to assemble a whole brain or to
erect individual structures on demand
[Music]
ideas generated in the brain of the
programmer excited by that nimble
process called imagination transferred
by nerves to muscles to finger movements
to the electrical mechanical complex of
the machine interact dynamically within
the computer the hand of the programmer
and the calculations of the computer
enable the human eye to visualize brain
structures as they have never been seen
before
[Music]
now especially constructed motion
picture camera and photograph the images
generated on the face of the computer
display and by the use of three primary
color filters superimpose any color of
choice on any selected still or moving
neural anatomical structures
[Music]
[Music]
here the cerebral ventricles are shown
in blue
they represent the cephalic elaboration
of the original neural tube around which
all of the structures of the brain are
organized during embryogenesis the two
lateral ventricles penetrate each lobe
of the cerebral hemispheres the rounded
anterior horns of the lateral ventricles
reach into the frontal lobes the
posterior horns occupy the central axis
of the occipital lobes the temporal
horns curve beneath to invade the
temporal lobes the lateral ventricles
connect by narrow channels with a single
midline third ventricle in this
particular brain the third ventricle has
a hole in its central region another of
the many variable features of
construction of the human brain the
third ventricle connects through a still
narrower Channel the cerebral aqueduct
with the fourth ventricle
[Music]
[Music]
the thalamus occupies both sides of the
third ventricle the thalamus provides
mainly for relaying information to and
from the cerebral cortex the
hypothalamus embraces the lower anterior
portion of the third ventricle
the pineal gland which Descartes
supposed to be the seat of the soul lies
directly behind the roof of the third
ventricle and above the brainstem here a
brain has been dissected in order to
show the combination of thalamus pineal
gland
and hypothalamus in the natural
post-mortem condition any such
structures after suitable preparation
can be sliced on the Cindy microtome
photographed traced digitized and
programmed into the computer
the brain stem is continuous with the
thalamus and hypothalamus it connects
these diencephalic structures to and
from the spinal cord
[Music]
one of the major motor control systems
of the brain is called the basal ganglia
downstream components of the basal
ganglia include the subthalamic nucleus
depicted in mauve color the red nucleus
which looks reddish in freshly cut
brains and the substantia [ __ ]
so-called because of its tendency to
accumulate black pigment here it appears
white in orientation among other
structures
[Music]
the basal ganglia in the forebrain
include the Globus pallidus named
because of its natural pallor in the
fresh state the putamen which has been
likened to a seashell and the caudate
nucleus which is named for its long
curving tail the basal ganglia in the
forebrain and in the diencephalon and
Mezen cephalic brainstem have to do
principally with postural and gestural
control of body musculature the
characteristic shape of the basal
ganglia is visible in this dissected
specimen
[Music]
the basal ganglia received projections
from all regions of the cerebral cortex
which activate mainly the putamen and
caudate nuclei
[Music]
the putamen and caudate nuclei project
and turn to the Globus pallidus the
Globus pallidus sends projections to and
receives impulses from the subthalamic
nucleus
the globus peles also sends fibers
forward to nuclei which lie deep within
the thalamus
[Music]
from the thalamus impulses are relayed
up to the motor cortex
the motor cortex receives an integrated
message from two major motor control
systems the basal ganglia and the
cerebellum signals from the basal
ganglia also course downward into the
basal ganglia nuclei and the
diencephalon and mesencephalon
[Music]
the subthalamic nucleus the red nucleus
and the substantia [ __ ]
such signals are also transmitted to the
diffusely projecting brain stem
reticular formation the cerebellum the
so called little brain sits on stout
stalks which arise from the brainstem
the gross anatomical relations between
cerebellum and brain stem can be seen in
this dissection the brainstem is
truncated at the level of the red
nucleus
the cerebellum is thought to regulate
sensory motor coordination of a
relatively automatic kind for example it
is concerned with adjusting the body in
recovery from displacement in space and
to coordinate the body within the
gravitational field the cerebellum
receives impulses from all areas of the
cerebral cortex it projects downward
into the brainstem and upward into the
thalamus by way of the red nucleus the
thalamus which relays impulses from
basal ganglia to motor cortex also
receives and relays impulses via the
same nuclei from cerebellum to motor
cortex
[Music]
the limbic system governs visceral
functions it is generally considered to
be the seat of emotional experience an
emotional expression the amygdala was
thought to resemble an almond it lies
directly in front of the temporal horn
of the lateral ventricle on each side
[Music]
bepah campus shown in purple looks like
a seahorse lying in the floor of the
lateral ventricles the two hippocampi
are interconnected across the midline by
the hippocampal comma sure
each hippocampus gives rise to a
distinctive bundle of fibers the fornix
here yellow orange
[Music]
the fornix passes both to and beyond the
septum and by relays to the mammillary
bodies
[Music]
in the posterior part of the
hypothalamus from the mammillary bodies
impulses travel upwards along the mammal
otha lamech tract
this tract connects the mammillary
bodies with the anterior nucleus of the
thalamus bilaterally
from this region of the thalamus signals
are distributed to a magnificent ring of
primitive cortex which forms a complete
circuit bounding the margins of each
hemisphere
[Music]
the limbic system consists then of an
array of cortical and subcortical gray
matter structures that ultimately
project to the anterior superior portion
of the brainstem in this dissection the
limbic system has been preserved in its
entirety along with some additional
structures which help to support the
limbic systems natural shape the
amygdala receives olfactory signals it
also shares projections to and from the
hypothalamus and back and forth with
neighbouring limbic cortex
[Music]
if a campus also connects with the
hypothalamus and with the local limbic
cortex it receives visual auditory and
somatic sensory input the hippocampus
also receives signals from the
hypothalamus and from the brainstem
these signals relate to bodily needs the
thalamus plays a very involved role by
interacting with all regions of the
cerebral cortex and conveying to the
cortex the outcome of activities in such
systems as the basal ganglia and the
limbic system one of the main outputs of
the hippocampus is by way of the fornix
to the septum and via additional relays
to the mammillary bodies from the
mammillary bodies impulses travel to the
anterior nucleus of the thalamus and on
from there to the bordering rim of
limbic cortex
[Music]
the limbic system completes a circuit of
communications like a crocodile biting
its own tail
[Music]
the limbic system
and the basal ganglia fit intimately
together both of these distinctive
functional systems are neatly packaged
within each cerebral hemisphere
a computer has taken data from one
person's brain and has revealed that
brains most important systems in
three-dimensional space underlying all
our membranes loaded with specialized
structures for discriminative reactions
to neurotransmitters electrical signals
and hormonal messages
[Music]
we do not yet know why the anatomy of
the brain is so different from one
person to another by taking advantage of
the marvelous projective capabilities of
the computer which can represent and
measure exactly volumes configurations
and topologies a new precision for
quantitative neurology of the human
brain can be obtained
mankind needs to know a great deal more
about the human brain not only at the
biochemical and cellular levels but also
at the level of quantitative comparisons
relating to the sizes and the topologies
of human brain structures cine
morphology aided by the computer can now
provide an exciting opportunity to
explore many aspects of what makes
humankind human
[Music]